all right well it's great to be here um
Tron Brown CEO of practice um first to
start uh I wanted to introduce myself
I'm from Santa Barbara California I grew
up surfing um and I I spent really my
whole childhood you know on the beach
and uh and and ended up homeschooling to
travel around the world compete in Surf
contests which afforded me this like
kind of interesting opportunity to have
uh
a different educational experience I was
homeschooled um and I I was really
interested in American Colonial history
U my family uh came to America from
Ireland uh they fought in the
Revolutionary War they built a fort um
they participated in the Pennsylvania
Constitutional
Convention and so this story of building
new cities of building new places of
building new countries was something
that I thought about you know from a
very young age and was able to really
dive into as a teenager and and you know
frankly like I was I was able to spend a
lot of time learning about Charter
cities and seing and these different
ideas when they were very nent um it's
me um and so I I ended up let's go back
I ended up moving to New York when I was
18 because I wanted to uh you know
pursue this sort of question is you know
of how does one build how does one build
a new city um you know in sort of
professional contexts I I went to intern
for a fund called persing Square um an
activist hedge fund um we invested in in
a company called Howard Hughes which
built uh three cities um in the United
States with over 100,000 residents um I
I left and did technology investing for
a couple years and then got a grant from
uh Tyler Cowen through EV to study the
development of new cities in Africa in
the Middle East um and I I learned a lot
about um you know the the Dubai
International Financial Center and
different sort of special economic Zone
Frameworks that were super helpful in
terms of developing new cities um I I
wanted to do something along those lines
and eventually um came back to the US uh
right when 2020 started uh and and Co
hit and I was sort of forced you know to
confront this question of how do I work
on building a new city you know stuck in
this tiny apartment in New York can't go
anywhere how do you build a city from
your apartment that was sort of the
premise that was the question um and the
answer I came to was like you know
people move to cities to plug into
social networks um and if we could build
a community around this charismatic
concept of uh you know building a new
city of building a new city around uh an
idea an idea of a more vital way of life
um that that might draw you know a lot
of really compelling people to um to to
the effort to the project and that those
people would represent a demand proof
Point uh that we could fund raise
against and that was sort of the premise
that was the idea um and and that's what
we ended up working on so we launched
practice um we we decided as a group
that we wanted to build the city in the
Mediterranean um and uh and and really
develop this sort of philosophy along
those lines that you know we're going to
build a new city on the Mediterranean uh
focused on technology focused on uh you
know building a a community of of people
who want to build technology companies
in a special economic zone that that
really facilitates that in one of the
most beautiful places in the world um
yeah so this is our our mission um we
were able to build a team um that has a
lot of experience we hired the the
former CEO of of Howard Hughes the
company we invested in at persing uh who
built three cities in the US with over
100,000 residents um we work with two
former Prime Ministers and we have a
bunch of other super talented people on
the team um we were able to raise money
from some really great investors um you
know Paradigm Bedrock a bunch of great
Angels um um and a large uh pension fund
that um has A1 billion do real estate
fund
um and so in in 2021 we launched uh we
launched this community um and really
were focused on building a new culture
um around this this idea of building a
new city
um we we built the community to uh you
know 12,000 12,000 members we have 250
residents that have committed to move um
we have a weit list of almost 50,000
people and those people met up all
around the world and you know hosted
events with one another um you know made
memes messed around on the internet uh
created culture and and you know many
started companies together um a lot of
people lived together in the community
there actually been a few marriages that
have come out of practice which has been
pretty cool
um yeah and so I guess yeah built this
really big Community it's pretty awesome
got to travel around the around the
world for a couple years meeting with
people who wanted to you know live in a
new city and and sort of explore this
idea together and then once we raised
money we we went back to all the
founders in the community and talked to
them about what it would actually take
for them to set up operations in a new
city um really it turned out that that
the core things were regulatory change
and economic incentives um that if we
could uh basically aggregate demand from
a bunch of different Industries we could
talk to a bunch of different Founders
from a bunch of different Industries and
figure out sort of like what policy
changes would unlock their willingness
to move to a new place um that if we
could sum up uh the the investment
amounts of all of those companies moving
to a new country um it'd be quite a lot
of foreign direct investment flowing
into that country um and that we could
go to a country with that offer um of
you know bringing all these super
talented people uh and all these
companies on the basis of these
regulatory changes and economic
incentives um and then wrap that sort of
like foreign direct investment in a
narrative of a beautiful Green New City
um that'll invest in Social uh social
goods for the local community that it
would become like a really compelling
political narrative for um you know for
for that country and for that Community
um and then on that basis we got uh our
first offer from a government to bring
our community of tens of thousands of
talented people the companies that want
to move on the basis of these incentives
um and this story of you know building a
really compelling future for uh you know
for the community for the country um we
we got an offer from a country to set up
our city uh you know within their
borders on land that they would
contribute for equity in the project um
some of the infrastructure financed by
them uh in a regulatory sandbox in their
country um so that was super exciting um
right now we're working on soliciting
further offers from other governments
we're going to do more than one project
ultimately but um you know we haven't
committed to our location for the first
project yet um but we're we're going to
be begin development and in uh 2024 like
the beginning of next year um with our
our you know development team and then
um you know we'll have 10,000 residents
moveed to the city in 2026 which is like
pretty close um a lot of the sites that
we're looking at are not just Greenfield
sites they're they're actually sites
that have some infrastructure already
developed in some cases there are um
there already structures in place so
we're able to accelerate the sort of
timeline to getting people moved in um
pretty dramatically
um the other thing i' is like there's
this question of like how do you finance
new cities I think sort of like the
Quant like sort of like kind of C you
need to get to a V1 you know with the
with the cities like quite large like if
you're a hard tech startup maybe it's
like 100 Mil if you're a city you really
need like a billion dollars to to build
like a phase one that's like you know
meaningful um and so how do you raise a
billion dollars and the the answer that
we came to if we sort of circle back to
the beginning is you know bu building
you know sort of a Community First doing
this sort of these sort of new city
projects demand first so we built this
very large community got these
incremental demand proof points where
people started you know putting down uh
deposits or committing to make deposits
on a house in the city and then on that
basis we were able to unlock capital
from uh you know institutions that were
excited about uh you know the economics
and the story and so on um on the basis
of of these early demand proof points
which are uh very uncommon with you know
new city projects getting demand you
know proof points before there's even a
site or a country announced that's you
know bit it's like never happened I
would say um Tam's really large fun to
talk about big numbers
um right now we have a we have this
program called steel Visa so um if you
want to become a member of prais if you
want to move to one of our cities to
become a resident um you can apply for a
steel Visa it's my co-founder Charlie um
he looks great on his steel Visa the the
idea is it's a membership card now once
we sign and announce our deal with the
host government that'll host the city um
the steel Visa will become a golden Visa
it'll become uh you know a real golden
Visa that gives you uh rights to to work
and to live in the country we're
ultimately going to locate practice um
and yeah so you know apply if interested
um and you get a metal card that looks
like
that that's
practice um oh W 3 seconds left cool
thank
you